a technologically advanced and
self-proclaimed superior group are
hell-bent on unleashing something called
a snowflake I wipe out all they deem
inferior in the human race like I don't
know if they're supposed to be social
media allegory in here but it's it's
easy to see right it's not just me
[Music]
fast and furious presents hobbs and cha
that is a long title for this video so
hobbs and chavez the fast and furious
spin-off starring Hobbes everyone's
favorite likable cop and Shah everyone's
favorite killer of Han that's cool now I
got so basically there's a super virus
is gonna get okay it's not gonna get any
more believable as I explain the plot
but I'm going to it's ridiculous yeah
Idris Elba's the bad guy he's gonna
unleash this super virus and Hobbs and
shower the two who are gonna stop him
yep it's it's that ridiculous
it's also that fun first of all Jason
Statham in the rock the two they have
good chemistry I know I call him the
rock I will always call him the rock
every time I call him the rock I feel a
few people in the comment section being
all Hank Schrader like yeah he's not a
rock Murray he's a Dwayne Johnson I get
it I'm just always gonna call him the
rock but he is so good at being the big
brute muscle Jason Statham being the
sleek we call him sexy dude's got style
he's got finesse charisma that's what
we're going for but they both have
charisma - polar opposite badasses
having good chemistry with each other
just the banter back and forth right
there a lot of bickering a lot of banter
a lot of trying to one-up each other a
lot of dick jokes literally a lot of
phallic references in this one yeah that
told you about my dick you don't know
him but it is a Megalodon he doesn't say
that there are a few references to their
other works in this movie couple of
great cameos - like one in particular
it's the ones who recruit Hobbes and
Shaw would you realize the movie they've
been in together it's funny it's alright
they have good chemistry there's a
pretty sweet villain Idris Elba
I gave yourself that has been in plenty
of bad movies but he's never the bad
part of those bad movies not saying this
movie's bad I'm just illustrating the
power of the Idris save it aligning here
what does he say something like I'm
against my forgettin or something like
that I was like that is a man who knows
the exact movie he's in that everyone
can pull off the villain his dialogue in
this movie but he totally does somehow
just in the action sequences I was
thoroughly entertained you have to
suspend disbelief you can't logic this
movie but the movie set you up for that
but I call [ __ ] when a movie just
crosses the line of unbelievab ility it
all comes down to the world the box that
it set itself up with and if it steps
outside of that starts becoming too
unbelievable you can really hey I call
[ __ ] this movie lets you know out
the gate what you're in for you're in
for a ridiculous time a fun time a
kick-ass time but you can't logic it you
just you
have to suspend your disbelief if you
can do that you can have your Olympus
has fallen style fun time at the movie
actually it's very much the same both
are kind of they're thrown back to a fun
90s action movie movies that aren't
always made in today's day and age now
everything has to be super realistic and
on one hand I do appreciate that and the
other hand I missed the ridiculousness
of the 90s I like it when a movie can
throw back to that the first half of
this movie is the most unapologetically
fun time I had in the movie theater in
quite some time there not a point about
halfway through it became a little
choppy I felt like there were fifteen
minutes on the cutting room floor that I
just they're gone now I didn't see him
it's like with every action there's an
equal and opposite reaction right I feel
like I saw the reaction but didn't see
the action that led to that reaction
something happened in there and now
we're here as nothing deals with family
it is sweet I can't say it's in line
with the momentum of the first half of
the movie by the end I really enjoyed
Hobbes and Shaw there's a kick-ass 90s
action movie that was made 20 years
later than it probably would have been
like when a video game froze back to the
retro day slick axiom verge and
shovelknight those games that throwback
to old school games but enjoy and even
take advantage of the technology we have
now to make a bigger experience either
way I dug this movie like fast and
furious it evolved it was one of those
smart franchises that was like oh we
can't just be Point Break forever we
have to evolve into something more and
it did now it's taking us here and I
didn't expect this spin-off to be as
entertaining as it was but it was great
chemistry between the leads kick-ass
fighting exciting chase sequences it
just throws caution to the wind when it
comes to ridiculous I kind of need in a
movie like this and I got it if you
can't roll with it like if my
description makes you go it's clearly
not gonna be for you but if you're up
for a fun time in the movies let's say
give Hobbs and Shaw watch it's a great
time no alcohol is fired fry so Hobbs
and Shaw have you seen it what did you
think about it or what's your favorite
action movie of recent time
that's totally a throwback to the 90s or
80s shoot let's go back even further
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]